tchau
o o negócio do zinho sozinha a querer
londrina o valor na bomba deixada à
beleza dessa por cheque ou pinto luísa
pura ea boca lei
achei no umea e aí foi
senti um cheiro esquisito cdp ainda não
é minha boca
o presidente admite uma certa essa não
cara foi cansativa e na hora saiu de sua
obra que minha mãe deixou nessa área que
foi não traga ninguém para dentro de
casa e uma coisa que eu não faço é
desobedecer é muito aberto da manhã mas
o destino desobedece a tua mãe a paz
seja ensina que da peteca por baixo da
entrada do tamanduaí estou falando que
só tem biscoito cream cracker
um kit de de grozny ano começando aqui é
assim que tem na densa que pisar aonde é
que eu vou ter dinheiro para colocar
pizza pequena chegou a dizer que aqui há
gato está quebrado não está prestando e
minha mãe falou também que não não é
cabível
quanto mais a as quebras e fechou por
falar em um total que cada tomada de
março de entretenimento que tem aqui em
casa é que a credicard hall e se esquece
que assim aberta fechou na rua da hora é
eu não sou um homem olha falou que se
abriu em leve com 34 46 abril microonda
morre em outro dia
é um evento da mata é do tempo tirando
de segunda está lançando um conjunto
disse haddad
eu sabia amarelo e deixou o time dá pra
mim não me fala que quer dizer que isso
tudo é o único em que não me deixou nem
porque eu não sabia se eu soubesse
estava dividindo com você
não mas acho que é esse a gente resolve
tempo viu obrigado pela amizade próxima
com o chile x botafogo